[Musique]
toa morita été capable de se défendre
mais il n'a jamais osé ancien champion
de karaté au collège il a vécu l'enfer
du harcèlement le dj mais au japon
pendant des années ses bourreaux étaient
ses propres camarades
au club de foot ça lui arrivait de se
faire étrangler mettre à terre traînée
au sol
mais mon fils est un garçon calme
il n'est pas du genre à réagir et à se
défendre quand on le prend à partie
s'il avait riposté à l'époque il
n'aurait pas été autant victimes de
violences par la suite et ça continue à
le faire beaucoup réfléchir
à 13 ans tôt à morita cesse d'aller à
l'école il s'isole mais le harcèlement
continu en ligne
l'adolescent tente même de se suicider
le jour du tournage il est sorti pour
éviter notre présence
aujourd'hui atteints de stress post
traumatique il est toujours déscolarisés
c'est dans cet espace qu'il vit recul
à l'époque des faits l'école n'a pas
réagi sa mère est toujours en colère
contre le système éducatif pour éviter à
d'autres enfants l'enfer que son fils a
vécu elle a créé une association
[Musique]
oui bonjour ici le bureau des affaires
éducatives de la préfecture de saitama
elle joue le rôle de médiateur entre les
parents et l'école une vingtaine de
dossiers sont sur sa table en ce moment
dans toute la préfecture de saitama près
de tokyo
ici comme ailleurs au japon ces quinze
dernières années internet et les
messageries en ligne ont amplifié le
phénomène luigi mes
coups insultes humiliations sur les
réseaux sociaux japonais ces contenus
sensibles mais viraux circulent
librement
devant cet établissement tokyoïte
certains élèves parlent d'un effet de
meute contre lequel il est difficile de
lutter
dans les écoles au japon les élèves ont
tendance à créer des groupes à agir en
bande je pense que ça pourrait arriver
dans mon école
un événement mineur peut prendre
beaucoup d'ampleur quand il est diffusé
en ligne
j'ai déjà entendu parler de cas de
harcèlement dans mon école
c'était du harcèlement sur les réseaux
sociaux et les messageries en ligne en
fait c'est une forme de violence qui est
moins flagrante
[Musique]
autant de situations qui échappent
souvent au seul cadre scolaire et
peuvent mener au pire en 2020 le japon
faisait face à un nombre record de 499
suicides de jeunes
pour lutter contre le harcèlement à
l'école cette chercheuse a créé un
questionnaire confiée au personnel d'une
cinquantaine d'écoles japonaise il
permet de mieux identifier les élèves
victimes dans un pays où la santé
mentale reste tabou l'application sur
tablette permet plus de confidentialité
au japon l'école est d'abord un lieu
pour évaluer noté juger les enfants
avec les professeurs ils ont tous
général du mal à parler de leurs
faiblesses ou des émotions qu'il ressent
au fond d'eux
à l'école il y à un endroit où les
langues se délient un peu plus
facilement l'infirmerie dans ce lycée
tous les élèves qui s'y rendent doivent
répondre au questionnaire après deux ans
d'utilisation cette infirmière se
satisfait des résultats
certaines blessure bénigne cachent des
meurtrissures plus intimes
une fois un élève blessé s'est présentée
ici et grâce au questionnaire on a
compris que les marques qu'il portait
était dû à de l'auto mutilation et qu'il
avait des pensées suicidaires
avec ce système on a vraiment pu
agrandir le cercle de protection autour
des élèves si le nombre de cas de
harcèlement a officiellement triplé en
dix ans au japon
c'est selon elle le reflet d'une
augmentation des signalements une
libération de la parole peut être les
premiers fruits d'une loi votée en 2013
la loi a provoqué une prise de
conscience dans les écoles le nombre de
cas détectés de harcèlement a augmenté
parce que maintenant les adultes ont
conscience qu'ils doivent agir le plus
tôt possible at il un signe encourageant
mais dans ce pays d'uniformes il faudra
du temps pour que la situation
s'améliore
l'individualité la différence reste mal
lu au japon un proverbe y est même
particulièrement populaire le cloud qui
dépasse appelle le marteau